we're approaching the top of the hour
here in Pyongyang and right now crowds
are gathering outside the central train
station all eyes are on this big screen
for what we're told will be a major
announcement about the missile launch
you may recognize the newsreaders making
the announcement her name is beatta he
and she's essentially the face of North
Korean state TV every major event in
this country she's the one on television
he reads the official government
announcement North Korea launched an
intermediate-range ballistic missile the
Fah song 12
this is the first time that many of
these people are hearing about this
because they've ever been waited more
than 24 hours after the missile launch
to make their official announcement
their supreme leader Kim jong-un says
more missile launches toward the Pacific
will happen this he says is just a
prelude to future military options aimed
at Guam many people around the world are
frightened when they see things like
this how does it make you feel I feel
very proud of this really an achievement
he says I'm seeing the launch and feel
that our military is improving I feel
very proud to be Korean president Trump
says that launches like this show that
North Korea has contempt for its
neighbors what's your response
we're simply acting in self-defense he
says shot one yesterday we could shoot
one today maybe tomorrow we'll shoot 10
more missiles we have to do it to defend
our country
a lot of people in the outside world
worry that your future will be much
harder because your country does things
like this what would you like to tell
them she pauses as if she's searching
for the right answer bounnam duty under
army and the leadership of marshal Kim
Jong Un's she says you can conquer any
enemy
unsurprisingly everyone we spoke to here
said they are 100% behind their supreme
leader Kim jong-un
they state launches like this won't
leave their country isolated or
impoverished but in fact will make their
country stronger what else would they
say will Ripley CNN Pyongyang North
Korea